do you ever get any scholarship offers
when you were coming up yeah I had a
scholarship
yeah but yeah I had I had a scholarship
for her I had a scholarship in South
Carolina University
for what though
football to play football yeah what
position uh I I used to play uh slot
slot receiver so you're like uh Wes
Welker yeah yeah
you can't be like I feel like if you're
a short wide receiver that's kind of
what you got to do yeah but I want a lot
of I was like yeah you gotta be slopped
but I was um
I ain't like weight training so like it
ain't work for me you just didn't like
to actually lift weights it wasn't your
thing yeah no I'm not alone
so how long how long were you actually
you know participating in college I
didn't go to college oh you didn't go I
don't know so you were like [__] that
they didn't offer you enough money they
didn't offer you enough money yeah
that's for the scholarship I would have
got like five I'd probably ten you know
big booty got five million dollars to
play the drums he told me about it right
here I thought he said 15. 15 million
you never know yeah it's [__] listen if
you if you out here playing the drums
like that
you should you should start a band no I
work for sure like Tommy Lee got paid
that much money to play the drums you
know I'm gonna tell Boogie though yeah
let him know Boogie cap
oh yo let's get I I got to see this I
tried to tell him without telling him
I'm gonna tell him I fought with Boogie
oh he's great and we had a hilarious
talk he's a great dude yeah yeah yeah I
[__] with everybody though of course I
got to see that [__] though yeah five
million boy your ass it's dumb you start
rapping [__] this [__] yeah like
Drumline had to have been about you bro
yeah that [__] had to be about him Nick
Cannon won't even get in five minutes
five million for Drumline hell no what
the [__] you're getting five million boy
big Boogie we might need to go back to
that [__] I will manage you personally
me too I'll be a [__] manager
your old man you don't gotta run up and
down all these clubs and get them back
ends bro just play the drums play the
drums [__] this [__]
um I ain't had no scholarship like that
though uh talk about this album very
personal album obviously you're you're
naming it after you know your your
government yeah is this your most
personal because you're a very
vulnerable guy on record yeah man yeah
yeah yeah I would say this is my most
personal album
um yeah
multiple album tour just got announced
yeah yeah I mean 90 sold out Jesus yeah
that's so crazy yeah is it yeah I'm
proud of you bro because you [__]
listen I'm happy you're on fire bruh Hey
listen when we did the club event in
Phoenix yep I [__] with that [__] yeah
he was uh we gotta run it back on you'll
be out there July 31st go get tickets if
it's not sold out already it's sold out
oh it's sold out but but but
let's run it back we got to run it back
man I love Phoenix bro I need a house
out there you should get a house out
there a lot of people are doing that on
the low yeah I love that [__] yeah
that's that's my favorite place to go
lots of rappers live in Arizona but they
don't want people to know because they
don't want to like they don't want it to
be bone up like yeah they only they
wanted to be some low-key [__] yeah yeah
I [__] with Phoenix 11 11 baby the 31st
we're gonna figure it out it's a Monday
it's a weird night to do but we're gonna
win we're not but come on now we we're
gonna pack that [__] out
um no but talk about this album I may or
may not have heard uh The Savage of the
21 is on this thing yes the Savage of
the 21. yes the Savage of the 21. Mr 21
is on the album who else is on the album
future and Khalid of course yeah yeah a
lot of we're gonna take those versions
off when the deluxe come out those
versions coming off
wait you're taking the remix versions
off you know yeah yeah you know this
this is the bootleg character yeah where
we keep it real right well I mean listen
you got to kind of you got to put all
the versions on the album you gotta no
no no you don't you I mean you don't
have to but the label wants you to they
tricked me because they want that first
week that's what I'm gonna tell you
though to the artist that's out there
because ain't nobody telling me this
[__] y'all do not have to put all
versions if it's the it's all under the
same uh code IR SDS what's the name of
the code
code It's all under the same coding so
you don't have to put the remixes on
[__] no and they told me I had to and
that's why three of the same song is on
the album bro I never wanted to do that
[__] well you know I think the label
likes to
the listen French Montana want to put
lockjaw on an album after it was out for
like five years you know it's like you
gotta make it look good you know yeah no
yeah don't don't but don't artists to
artists that's out there
people think it look good and don't do
that [__] just put take the two songs
off and put another version and there
you go it's all in the same code and
ain't nobody tell me that [__] though